I'm often called both Muslim terror
apologist and an Islamophobe how one can
be both I don't exactly know the reality
is that most terror in the world is
committed by Muslims but most terror in
the u.s. is committed by white
non-muslim men mostly Christian if not
by personal religion certainly by sort
of casual upbringing by Christian
parents and the celebration at least
casually of Christian holidays and if
there were ever a counterpoint to the
counterproductive and illegal majority
Muslim country immigration ban of
President Donald Trump a mass shooting
took place on Sunday night at the
Islamic cultural center of Quebec City
in Canada where six people were killed
and 17 were injured when a lone gunman
started shooting right after evening
prayers had ended and this is a
terrorist attack a prime minister Justin
Trudeau has called that I've not really
heard anyone deny that where the victims
were Muslims and police say that of the
two men that they had initially had
contact with one has been arrested the
other was determined to have been a
witness rather than a suspect the
arrested man the alleged perpetrator
identified as Alexander Bissonnette who
is a 20-something year old regular white
dude not known to the representatives of
the Muslim community at the mosque he
was previously not known to police but
he was known within the city in activist
circles as a right winger who frequently
took anti-foreigner and anti-feminist
positions stood up for US president
Donald Trump and it really makes you
wonder not only what is the trigger that
makes someone go from a sort of online
and tagging as' and casual antagonist to
somebody who actually seeks out weapons
and end up shooting people that's a
question that's raised here but of
course it really exposes you know even
within the context of the Muslim ban and
I get that this is Canada okay I get
that but we've got very
discussions going on in both countries
about these issues it really makes you
say well even within the context of the
ban as we talked about yesterday the
primary sources of terrorists commit
four acts committed in the United States
those countries are missing from the
list we talked about Saudi Arabia we
talked about Lebanon etc but above and
beyond that it remains that there are
far more of these white american-born
terrorists in the United States and this
one in Canada then there are what this
Muslim immigration ban purports to keep
us safe from and I think it's very good
that Prime Minister Trudeau is calling
this out for what it is because I think
a lot of people in the American media
aren't willing to do so it doesn't
matter if the act is perpetrated with
guns or bombs or if the person's white
black whatever the color of their skin
is right of their nationality terrorism
is an act perpetrated on a means of
religion or politics and that's clearly
what this was and it is meant also to be
a sort of message to this is not a
message to the individuals that were
killed and there's no evidence
whatsoever that individuals were
targeted this was an attack targeted at
someone based on their membership in a
particular group in this case people who
are bus women go to a mosque when it's
white victims of hate crimes I called it
out a few weeks ago and in this case I
also am calling it what it is now I went
online the different right wing and
pro-trump enclaves of the internet just
to see what was their take on all of
this and I saw that there were comments
and discussion threads where the
trumpets and the alt writers were
condemning the attack they were even
talking about well maybe we could set up
a GoFundMe account for the victims to
make sure that this guy isn't associated
with our cause and it sort of made me
feel like maybe there was some hope
there even if it was mostly
opportunistic and trying to avoid being
wrapped in with this guy which again
this this seems to be a pro-trump
alt-right anti-feminist type that that's
abundantly clear that's what he is until
I started reading some of the more
detailed comments where of course it was
being called a false flag operation to
deliberately undermine the
Muslim ban you would think Pat that if
there was a false flag event like this
that they would do it in the United
States not in Canada or is that just the
deliberate subtlety of the whole thing
it's part of the false flag operation
yes that it occurred in a different
country I mean a subreddit isn't
necessarily the best cross-section of
Trump supporters and it's good that some
of those people in that community are
condemning this attack but there's
always going to be those conspiracy
theorists out there the other
interesting thing that was going on on
discussion forums online on right wing
websites Reddit etc was saying hey we
shouldn't we shouldn't judge all Trump
supporters all all writers all
anti-feminists based on the actions of
one single extremist terrorist where
have I heard that before and it was
completely ignored by people oh right in
this entire Muslim majority Muslim
country immigration ban that we've been
talking about for the last 48 hours
it was truly stunning I mean the
hypocrisy the total cognitive dissonance
here and no indication again from the
police that anybody else was involved
some on the right say I won't talk about
attacks when Muslims are the
perpetrators the truth is the opposite I
talk about it all the time but then some
on the Left say I won't talk about
stories where Muslims are the victims
because again I'm an Islamophobe but
again Here I am talking about it what is
abundantly clear here is that this
immigration ban of the u.s. that we've
been talking about its optics and PR it
is not a serious way to keep Americans
safer it is abundantly clear that that's
the case as we have seen the the band
start to be talked about positively in
the sense of it being a great recruiting
tool for many extremists and jihadist
and Islamic state associated groups
there is no evidence that it is actually
going to make Americans safer and if
that's actually what you care about then
you should be judging it based on that
not on the optics or this arbitrary it
was a promise that Trump is keeping type
of thing and we're going to talk about
that a little bit more today